hello everyone happy Boxing Day I've
been feeling in the giving mood so I
want to regifter a fun little facebook
life that we did just a few days before
my cookbook the mindful Glo cookbook
came out it's just one of my favorite
recipes for my buffalo chicken egg rolls
with blue cheese dip and it's so good I
could not not share it with you guys
here on the YouTube channel if you guys
are not already following me on Facebook
get on over to my facebook page the link
will be right in the description below
you're going to want to subscribe so you
do not miss another fun little Facebook
live and if you don't already have your
copy at the mindful Club cookbook this
week be an amazing time to get on it
because it's boxing week you're probably
already in the mall and this would be an
amazing little gift for yourself so
let's do it
hello everyone thank you so much for
joining me and my facebook live happy
Friday I'm really excited because my
book the mindful Glo cookbook is coming
out in 1 2 3 4 slips Oh honestly it's
like it's like Christmas morning for me
so I'm really excited to share with you
when my favorite recipes from the book
I'm gonna get out for you this is my
buffalo chicken egg rolls with a blue
cheese dip so just check this out for a
hot minute oh my god how good is that
look this is one of the fan favorites in
the studio when we were shooting the
book so it was kind of like an ask for
everybody that was here like can we make
the buffalo chicken egg rolls because
they are so delicious they are so
perfect for entertaining so if you guys
are planning to do some holiday
entertaining and you need a really fast
amazing recipe for whipping up on the
fly this recipe is so great because you
can actually make it a head freeze it
and then bust it out at the last minute
for those
unexpected guests that just kind of show
up at your door you're going to love
love this so I'm really excited to get
right into it of course we're gonna be
taking all of your questions and don't
forget if you don't have your copy of
the mind flow cookbook pre-ordered what
are you waiting for it you want to get
on that right away we've got a link in
our description so check it out as soon
as you possibly can
because it's going to be so so good I'm
so excited to share this with you this
my whole heart and soul went into
writing this book so I'm really really
excited for you get to see it so we're
gonna get started here we're gonna make
a really quick little buffalo chicken
sauce so I'm gonna set this right here
get on our heat and we're going to start
with some hot sauce so you can use like
the Tabasco I'm using like a Frank's
redhot you can kind of use whatever
you've got I'm gonna add most of that in
here just saving a little bit aside I'm
just gonna put it to like a medium heat
or so that's probably gonna be enough
we've got some butter you know I am a
all food Spitz kind of dietitian I know
you guys know that so I believe in the
power of butter yes you can use
margarine you could use probably use
olive oil if you really wanted to but
traditional chicken wings have a little
bit of butter in there so you know let's
just enjoy that I'm gonna add some lemon
juice I'm gonna give that a good squeeze
these are all my favorite lights so we
got like the little bit of tartness
you've got the the spiciness and then
one second all right let's get these
guys out of the way we need a little
sweet so I've got a little honey again
you could use regular sugar if you
really want to but I like the aromatics
of honey let's get that guy in alrighty
and then with our residual hot sauce
here we've got just a touch of
cornstarch I'm just gonna add that
because basically what I'm gonna do is
make a little slurry so a slurry is just
gonna help thicken up our sauce really
nicely
just like that beautiful pizza all right
so this is starting to melt down you can
see I've got my butter in here we've got
some of that honey and it's just going
to incorporate into our hot sauce this
is basically going to be the flavor that
we're adding to all of our chicken so
once that's melted just gonna take a
second get a little more heat in here
and you can make a huge huge batch of
these if you wanted to it's it's so easy
because you could just dump a whole like
little jar of the hot sauce in there add
in our ethanol dose butter and the
ingredients and you could set it up all
ahead of time all right so let's add in
our slurry and we're just gonna let that
thicken all right so let's give that a
quick little stir so you can see we've
got all of our ingredients in here but
let's just give it a couple more seconds
just to kind of thicken up a little bit
one second
there we go so once it starts to bubble
that's basically all you need to do it's
gonna thicken with that cornstarch
slurry in there and that's when we can
start to add in our chicken now don't
forget if you have any questions as we
go along today be sure to ask them I'm
going to be answering questions in live
time we've got our stream here so I'm
just gonna take a quick look how we're
looking it's a lot to manage when you're
doing a Facebook live folks all right so
I'm just gonna make sure I've got them
ready to go in case there we are amazing
all right so let's get this heat up just
a hair so we can get a little bit of a
bubble but this is definitely one of our
favorites this is from the happy hour
section of my cookbook in the mindful
glow basically all of your best recipes
for entertaining because leat let's be
real we need recipes that are super
simple
when we are crazy busy and the holidays
are coming and I know that it can be a
really hectic time for all of us so this
is particularly when we need those kind
of cheater meals and this is a really
great great option for that because
we're using a store-bought rotisserie
chicken and yes yes yes you could cook
your own chicken and
that would be amazing but not all of us
have time for that all the time
especially around the holidays when when
you know people are coming around on and
out and you've got a holiday shopping to
do there's this a lot going on but like
I said the books and my flow cookbook
it's available online currently for
pre-order at Amazon and then of course
it's gonna be an indigo and all of the
all of your kind of local stores in just
a few days next Tuesday on December 4th
so you're not going to want to miss out
on it's gonna make an amazing holiday
gift for literally everyone on your list
because we've got lots of great recipes
I mean this is not a vegan recipe but
we've got gluten-free recipes and vegan
recipes and vegetarian high-protein and
I really try to make sure that there was
something for everyone and I think that
that's really the key in general when
you are entertaining you need to make
sure that there are lots of great
options for basically everybody on your
list all right so this is starting to
thicken this would be when you kind of
take a little step back because of
course we don't want to ruin our
ensemble and get ourselves out messy but
just let's give it a quick second here
and in the meantime I'm going to just
get rid of some of these little dishes
and we'll get at the rest of our
ingredients all right so this is
definitely what you're looking for
you're looking for it to get kind of
bubbly and a little bit thicker so I
think the most important thing here is
that I remove my white cookbook from the
set because it is just too pretty to get
all dirty now having said that do I want
you to get your cookbook dirty yes I do
because it means that you are showing it
lots of love in the kitchen but about
for us today we're going to get key to
the side all right let's get this out so
okay here we go so that's pretty much
looking like it's ready to go I'm just
going to turn that down now we'll let
that set for a second what I've got here
as you can see I've got some shredded
chicken so I just took up store-bought
rotisserie chicken and and shredded it
up there's something like really
cathartic about shredding chicken I
don't know what it is just like pulling
that meat off the bone and just
like going to town with it but we're
going to use that I've also taken some
celery and carrots because as you
probably know when you buy when you buy
like chicken wings you often get little
pieces of celery and carrots on the side
so I kind of wanted to throw that flavor
into the game here so we're gonna add
that to our mix I've got carrots celery
all diced up and ready to go
then let stand you've got a spoon so
let's give that a stir and we're going
to go in with our sauce so just look at
how yummy and bubbly that is it smells
so good it's like spicy and feet and
kind of tangy it's like totally
addictive all right
so let's just give that quick little get
all that goodness out get in there buddy
oh that's so good all right
so I'm just gonna give everybody a nice
little coat here in the sauce now I do
think that you would do not want to skip
that cornstarch cornstarch slurry step
because I find that if you were to just
like put hot sauce straight on the
chicken it gets so kind of soggy once
you cook them and then the sauce ends up
basically all over the baking sheet and
not in your delicious egg roll so we
want to keep that flava intact here
alright so this is looking pretty good
this is what we're looking for and this
is where we can have a little bit of fun
and I highly recommend I mean maybe not
if you want them to look presentable but
I recommend you get your kids involved
in that have some fun with this and this
is what we get to roll and yeah some of
them might look a little wonky but that
is totally a ok because that's the fun
of cooking right so we're going to start
rolling right here and I've taken a
little you know a dish towel or piece of
paper towel I like to put it on top of
my egg roll wrappers to keep them a
little bit more
hydrated because they do tend to kind of
get a little bit hardened as we work
with the rest of our egg roll wrappers
but you can see I've got a nice egg roll
wrapper here we're going to put it in a
diamond configuration so just like that
there water I just have some water here
this is not oil or anything like that
and I'm going to move this over here so
we're going to take our water put your
fingers into the water this is not just
for cleaning them but actually for
adhering our egg roll wrapper together
so I put a little in the corners all
around basically I like to make a like a
box so just like that take some of our
mixture I always find I get a little
overzealous with filling these things so
try to keep them like all uniform that
would be my like otherwise like some end
up being like huge and some end up being
like really understaffed and yes it's
going to get messy so I recommend having
some paper towel close by for
reinforcements all right so get get it
so it's in this that kind of lower half
here but it's not quite touching the
outside corners because that's where we
need to roll so you can see I probably
have about a quarter cup of filling in
my on my egg roll wrapper we're gonna
take the bottom corner oh I got a chili
pepper in my mouth but it tastes so good
I can't can't not go back for more
all right so give it a nice roll like
this did it did to death and then we're
going to tuck in our sides tuck in our
sides trying our best to like make sure
there's no like little little holes for
the goodies to escape you know we don't
want to we don't want any casualties and
then just do a nice little cuckoo roll
you have to make that sound of fact when
you do it the COO that's part of the
cooking method if you don't do it they
don't turn out so I highly recommend you
get in on the sound effects alright
let's do a few more here
now let's sick take a peek so over here
we go just like that
we'll do a few more
just in this so the bottom half I find
is the best place to put it because then
you've got more space to roll to prevent
any leakage happening that's really what
we're trying to prevent here
okay so around in and and roll you could
also do this with spring roll wrappers I
just find that the the consistency of
the egg roll wrappers are a little bit
better for baking it's totally different
when you're frying them but because
we're trying to keep this a little bit
lighter for the holidays there's already
enough indulgent stuff going on that I
find that the the egg rolls are wrappers
are a lot more hearty and sturdy for
this kind of filling alright so a few
more and you could make these I mean I
use the whole rotisserie chicken of
course I don't want to be wasteful I'm
not gonna buy a half a wrote a whole
rotisserie chicken then only use the
white need but if you are like really
adamant that you only want to have white
meat then you could absolutely just kind
of use the breasts or if you want to
cook them yourself you could just just
cook the breasts that also totally works
so another kind of quick little roll
here and out we go
you could also if you wanted to make
these mini if you were like doing like a
little fun appetite hors d'oeuvre party
and you want to make these like super
cute bite sized so they're just like a
one biter
you can cut the egg roll wrappers into
smaller pieces it just would become a
little bit more tedious and let's be
real at the holidays I'd rather have
people have more bites for less work I
don't know about you but that's that's
kind of my mandate at this time of year
there's just too much going on to really
fuss too much about little tiny hors
d'oeuvres with a million different
components you've got to make it super
simple for yourself because there's just
there's just too much to have to worry
about but I was gonna say kids would be
fantastic at helping out with this
because you can see like it not much can
go wrong at this point there's nothing
at this the feelings not really
particularly hot they're not gonna burn
themselves yeah there might be some
leakage happening might be some
casualties but at the same time it's
part of the holiday fun is to get
kids into the kitchen my little ones
probably still a little bit too young
for this but but one day one day one
will be very excited so I'm gonna just
do a few more and show you how I'm going
to cook these off so as you can see
we've got our egg or egg rolls lined up
of course you would finish off the rest
of them but I don't necessarily wanted
to do them all quite yet and I'm using
an oil atomizer if you don't have an oil
atomizer get one that's like my first
tip but my second tip is actually I
don't know I haven't tested this oh yeah
cuz I broke it
that's really great didn't test it but
that's okay so what we're gonna do
instead is I'm just going to put a
little bit of oil drizzle it on top this
is how you get really resourceful at the
last minute so the reason I like an oil
atomizer other than when it's broken is
that I like to be able to get a nice
light spritz of oil on on baked goods
because this way you make sure that you
are getting like even browning as
opposed to some of they fine if you're
brushing you're gonna add a lot more oil
or if you're kind of kind of trying to
dunk then you're obviously going to get
kind of patches that are covered in oil
whereas when you're baking a lot of
these kind of like faux fried foods it's
a really great way to minimize the
amount of oil you're using but at the
same time ensuring a nice even coverage
so it's kind of one of my favourite
little kitchen appliances when it's
working but I've recently broke this so
that's not so great but what I'm going
to just do is kind of quickly just give
it a nice quick little rub the other
nice thing is it kind of acts the same
way that like a nonstick spray would
like Pam for example and there's nothing
necessarily wrong with Pam but I like
that I can control the quality of the
oil so this way I'm using like my best
olive oil that like I like to like put
on my salad or I like to cook with
regularly versus you know a vegetable
oil with with with different kind of
other ingredients in there to help with
the with the spray technology so this is
definitely a little bit lighter for us
okay so that's basically what we're
doing with that
let's just reassemble my my faulty
eggroll spritzer
give yourself a nice little hand wash
and these are going into our 400 degree
oven so over here there we go so this is
going in for about 10 minutes and what I
do is I put in for 10 minutes just as is
and then in ten more minutes I give them
a flip because ultimately there's going
to be browning happening on the bottom
we want to make sure that they're evenly
browned on either side so let's just
kind of tidy up some of this stuff
because we have to do a dip it's not a
fun party up unless there's a dip that's
I'm pretty sure that that's like party
rule number one you need dips you need
lots of day so let's come over here and
I'm gonna get my food processor out you
could use a blender for this you could
actually just skip it altogether and
like not worry so much about it and just
kind of do it by hand if you don't mind
a little bit more of a chunky texture
but I kind of like things in smooth when
it comes to dips especially when
something else is dipping into it and
you want to make sure that that is
getting even coating so I'm just gonna
throw this on you know that all food
processors have their own personality
right so you have to figure out how
exactly it locks into place and that is
alone a skill that you know can't be
taught as far as I'm concerned so here
we go so basically with the dip we are
doing a blue cheese dip but the reason I
love this dip is that it's a lot lighter
than most store-bought blue cheese dips
because we're using Greek yogurt in that
so it's really gonna add some protein
it's going to lighten it up and I find
that I like the consistency better than
I do like a lot of traditional blue
cheese dips which I find are just a
little bit heavy for me so first things
first you need good quality blue
I wouldn't skimp on this because you
need the flavor without adding an
excessive amount of it so use a nice
soft one that will easily incorporate
into the rest of our mixture here so
this is going in to our food processor
yes see I don't even know the
personality is just I don't know this
personality yet I'm still getting to
know them we are we're still becoming
friends and and it's it's it's been a
long day so I have to I have to still
kind of learn the ropes when it comes to
this food processor but we've got our
blue cheese in I think we are good to go
we're gonna add our Greek yogurt here
I'm doing like a full fat Greek yogurt
do not skimp on the fat when it comes to
Greek yogurt because you know a lot of
that that full fat dairy is often a lot
better for us so I'm much more prefer to
use a good quality full fat Greek yogurt
than the fat free stuff that I find it's
just so tart it kind of ruins all the
recipes now over here
I've got this is an olive oil Mayo which
I really like so that's going in and I'm
just using a little bit cuz like I said
before most of these blue cheese dips
are just blue cheese and Polly some Mayo
so this is a nice way to kind of cut
that with that Greek yogurt I've got
some garlic going in just minced it up
fresh garlic some more lemon juice so
let me just get this going so this just
oh it smells really good mmm
and if you don't like blue cheese dip
because I know it's like you know are
you a ranch gorilla you a blue cheese
girl you can totally skip it and do
whatever kind of dip that you like with
your chicken wings I know everyone has
like their own preferences when it comes
to that or you just enjoy them own
natural that's another option but I am
partial to a good dipping action little
salt a little salt salt salt and a
little pets all right
and let's let's see if let's see if I've
learned the personality that's it
[Music]
alright that's looking pretty good
that's looking pretty good
alright so that's awesome I'm just gonna
scrape down the sides here don't smell
so good guys it's smells so good and I'm
really excited because I already have
some ready because I can't wait 20
minutes
oops but I have some all rage go so I
wanted to show you what this is going to
look like when it comes together and the
beautiful thing about this recipe is you
can make it ahead of time and and then
you can actually freeze them on a baking
sheet in a single row so you don't want
them to be all frozen on top of each
other
that way when they it's basically flash
freezing for an hour it only takes like
an hour of your time then after that
then you can put them into a freezer bag
and they can all go together and and
hang out and be friends and hold hands
but once once they're all frozen they
can stay there you could do them a few
months in advance and that when the
party happens you say okay I'm gonna
pull those guys out of the freezer 350
degrees it only takes like 10 to 15
minutes just to warm them back through
and the dip you just saw it took like a
hot minute so you've got a really easy
little app in just no time at all just
going to wipe down my my station here
just like that and I want to show you
how easy it is to put these together so
basically all I've done like I said is I
have flipped those egg rolls it took me
just 10 minutes and then another 10
minutes until they're nice and crispy
and you're gonna see you're gonna see
how beautiful and golden-brown there and
you'll know that they are ready to go so
look at this I'm just gonna finish it
with my my dip here I've got this
adorable little Rani little ramekin with
our beautiful fluffy that is it's so
good it's so yummy and savory mmm this
is one of my faves alright so this is
going in I feel like I need to take a
little taster
because amazing first we've got a
comment / question on a sec gonna have
to just do a little refresher freshing
action alright Internet let's be fast oh
look at this okay come on come on okay
here we go
love buffalo chicken does it have
vegetarian vegan and meat recipes yes
so the mindfully cookbook has literally
you know something for everyone I really
tried to make it so that it wasn't just
tailored to one particular kind of group
or a particular diet there's something
for the vegetarians your life the vegans
in your life gluten-free if you want to
cut back on the sugar if you've got a
nut allergy we call out all of these
things so it's really easy for you to
identify which recipes are going to be
best for you and your family depending
on your preferences and depending on
your dietary needs so yes there's lots
this is a one of my favorite meat based
recipes but I actually have so many
vegetarian and vegan recipes in the book
payer hot spot for favorite hot sauce
marry sharps from Belize oh that sounds
really good I have not tried that can
you make with this this with other meats
yes you definitely can make this with
other meats pork would be particularly
delicious I would say you want to do
something that is shredded so that's
easy for you to when you take a bite
it's not just like you're not getting
like a chunk of something so a shredded
meat like a pulled pork would be really
good pulled turkey would be really yummy
leftover turkey obviously you guys are
gonna have well if you're in my family
we don't have any leftover turkey just
kidding but if there is anything from
your leftover roast throw it in there
a brisket would be great too if you want
to kind of shred up a brisket so lots of
great options for you guys there and so
let's do a little dip action cuz I've
kind of been waiting for it for this
moment not that I want to like say
goodbye to you but I just want to have a
snack so you know they go hand-in-hand
but so like what more could you ask for
mmm soup first of all how do you do
those look second of all we've got so
much chicken in here and we got some
vegetables so I feel pretty good about
this right now I'm feeling pretty good
and then we've got that delicious sweet
kind of spicy tangy a hot sauce in there
and yes you could like tone it down if
you if you found that the sorry my mouth
is watering so I can't talk it's just so
good if you felt that it was too spicy
for you you could always use a more mild
hot sauce or if you're serving this to
your children or something like that but
hey I lost a little bit of a kick you
could also kick this up a hardcore if
you want to like make a batch for like
the Daredevils in your family
or you just want to if you just hate
someone then you can just throw that one
on their plate but you can definitely
play with the heat level that's
something that is totally easy for you
to to adjust based on your family's
needs and and what their what their
preferences are the other thing I was
gonna say is if you've got vegans in the
group you could definitely do this with
old jackfruit I am seeing so many more
recipes online for pulled Jack through
as a vegan alternative to pulled meat
there's would be an amazing place to try
out something like that so you can also
I find by a lot of jackfruit products
jack fruit products la la la so all you
have to do is just literally add it in
just as easy as it was for me to add in
a rotisserie chicken so like you saw
this recipe took me no time at all yet
it's surprisingly fun really really
impressive and your guests are gonna
love it because it's a little bit
lighter too so it's not like you are
having another deep-fried appetizer that
we often are seeing put out on the
spread during the holidays I'm not sure
if we have any more questions but if we
don't I'm definitely going to be able to
answer any more questions that come in
after live I hope you enjoyed this but
more importantly I hope you enjoyed the
book I'm not going to touch it right now
because I'm covered in hot sauce and
my little my little grimy fingers would
get all over it but I really am so
excited to see it come to life next week
so I like I've said for more sleeps
until the mindful glow cookbook is in
stores you can find the link for you to
pre-order in the description so do not
miss out on that but the recipe book has
over a hundred beautiful recipes for
really inspiring the healthiest happiest
you that was my goal with mindful glow I
really wanted to make sure that that the
the recipes were so inherently delicious
that you would never think to slap on a
diet or a healthy food label because
what I truly believe is that food needs
to be pleasurable first and foremost
especially at the holidays when you know
we're just trying to enjoy ourselves and
food really should be enjoyable and when
we choose those foods that we actually
love and actually enjoy hello we
actually start to notice the inherent
delicious of some of really great for
you food like chicken and so obviously
so rich in protein and we've got
vegetables and and Greek yogurt these
things become like so much more enticing
and more exciting to us and then all of
those kind of like forbidden foods like
the fried foods that maybe you you
limited yourself on before or the
chicken wings the actual chicken wings
that you never let yourself have anymore
they're no longer so enticing either no
longer so exciting so you don't feel the
need to kind of like go and eat three
pounds of chicken wings on a bender on
Friday night when you can have something
that is just as delicious so I'm so
excited to share this book with you guys
I hope you enjoy it I would love love
love if you would share any photos that
you have when you get the book in your
hands I want to see what you're making I
want to see your fingerprints all over
that book and I would love to see which
recipes you guys are enjoying the most
so please definitely don't forget to tag
me on any of my social media in
platforms when you are sharing recipes
use the hashtag mindful glow so that I
can keep track of all the amazing
deliciousness
you guys are getting up to so thank you
so so much for joining me today happy
Friday
enjoy
weekend and I will see you next week
when mindful glow comes out ah bye so
guys I hope you enjoyed my we gifted
Facebook live and my recipe for these
buffalo chicken egg rolls with blue
cheese dip now if you didn't get out to
the mall I mean I don't blame you it's
probably really crazy there right now
you can always pick up your copy online
in the link below and do not forget once
you receive yours and you've given it a
good look and you've tried some great
recipes please please please share your
adventures with me on social media using
the hashtag mindful slow and don't
forget to leave me a review online
through indigo or through Amazon thank
you guys so much I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]